there is a really big deal being made
out of a breaking story
from investigative reporter carl carl
bernstein of woodward and bernstein
fame about 21 republican senators who
privately have been saying
anti-trump things and i am here to tell
you
i do not care if they don't say it
publicly
and they didn't say it publicly for the
last four years
who cares that they were privately
willing to say it to carl bernstein
um you know there's a couple
possibilities here
either they weren't saying it publicly
because for a while they supported trump
or they weren't saying it publicly
because they thought that it was better
for their own careers to shut their
mouths
either way their silence was terrible
for the country for the last four years
but we'll come back to that okay carl
bernstein tweeted yesterday
and dozens of articles were written
about this
the 21 republican senators who have
privately expressed their disdain for
trump
are portman alexander sas
blunt collins murkowski cornyn
thune romney braun young
tim scott rick scott rubio grassley burr
toomey mcsally moran roberts and shelby
of the people on bernstein's list some
did actually criticize
trump publicly like ben sasse uh
john cornyn occasionally lisa murkowski
certainly mitt romney but i have to tell
you i'm finding myself
completely underwhelmed by this donald
trump has represented an existential
threat to the american system of
democracy and government and way of life
for four years a couple of senators have
mildly criticized donald
trump and even the ones that did a
little more harshly
mitt romney for example you know john
kasich
within days of joe biden winning they
went
right back to saying my goal is stopping
medicare
for all we've got to stop tax increases
we've got to deal with the debt we have
to you know reduce
business regulations so if anyone
expects me to praise republican senators
who privately criticize donald trump
give me a break guys
imagine if from day one of this
presidency
or six months in you know whenever it
was abundantly clear to everybody that
this was a disaster imagine if early on
21 republican senators had actually
stood up regularly
and strongly criticizing donald trump
that actually could have made a
difference
instead now that joe biden has already
won
we hear oh 21 of them said things in
private about trump to carl bernstein
give me a break
these people are pathetic now one other
aspect of this
trump and republicans love to say it's
the left
that doesn't allow dissenting opinions
and it's the left that doesn't want to
engage in the battle of ideas
these 21 republicans if it is
true that they really didn't like what
donald trump was doing
they partially stayed quiet because they
were too
scared to say anything they were afraid
of being
outed publicly as not liking donald
trump
when trump was still riding high this is
what we call
profiles in cowardice they aided
and abetted trump and if indeed
they felt this all along they have to be
held accountable now
for how donald trump has debased
democracy for four years and i mean
think back to impeachment guys
everyone but romney who did vote to
convict on one count on impeachment
if these other 20 republican senators
had voted to convict trump on
impeachment
they'd have been able to remove him and
they wouldn't have had to worry
about the repercussions of coming out
against donald trump
truly pathetic none of these people
should be held up as heroes
in fact what they are is disingenuous if
indeed
nearly half of the republican senators
in the senate
privately were disturbed distraught and
against what donald trump was doing
what they need to be uh uh sort of uh
what the what we need to be pointing the
finger to
um is that they were completely
disingenuous in public and continuing to
support donald trump completely pathetic
i'm glad we learned about it these are
not heroes these are not our friends and
as we saw from mitt romney and john
kasich within 24 hours of the election
they obviously and predictably as we've
been saying for years
went right back to the exact type of
republicans they were
before donald trump i want to let you
know that our sponsor vincero watches is
having a massive holiday sale on
all of their products right now and you
can take advantage of it by going to
davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality wrist
swatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over 25 000
five-star reviews because you won't find
a better-made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video